hi guys my name is Cameron chambers and
this is Tamra Jessa today I am reacting
to seeing the circle which was a pretty
movie with good actors but no conflict
and then below and today Cody is
performing stand-up at Haven con in
Texas wearing one of his shirts though
he's that amazing merch
this one says radical empathy and my
favorite shirt of all time so I feel
like this movie should have been
something that was really thriller II
and that kind of like scared me in a way
of not like horror scaring but just like
life commentary scary and it wasn't it's
a book that they turn into a movie and
you get the sense that there's there's
part they kind of skim over that would
have been really thrilling in the book
I'm sure I bet the book was awesome this
wasn't awesome so the movie is about the
circle which is a giant corporation
that's kind of Google X but if Google
Plus had turned into what Facebook is
it's like this social media but also
just internet platform they do a really
good job of that like they have fun work
environments and then good perks and
they throw concerts for their workers
and it like yeah okay I can see that
that's viable cool nuts revealed that
they're kind of going way too far with
us with private e private e privacy
settings it's something that is very
deep-rooted scary for a lot of people
especially people who spend a lot of
time on the Internet
is that your privacy is slowly going
away this just takes it to such an
extreme that it doesn't really hit as
hard as I thought it would I thought it
would be a lot scarier for me you know I
feel that way like oh I'm always
broadcasting everything I'm doing online
by my own choice but I that's what I do
and it's my job and so a movie about
that is pretty terrifying but this to
take it to the extreme to the point
where she only has three minutes to use
the bathroom
before her live feed is turned back on
so Emma Watson is an employee at the
circle and she decides to go full
transparent which means that she is
always live and there's billions of
people watching her and it felt very
like ultimate vlogger II you can see
kind of comments popping up and that
aspect of it was cool I enjoyed the
comments that you could see people just
watching her everyday life very much
reminded me of vloggers on YouTube who
put everything up all day every day and
it was very similar to that but that was
pretty much the whole movie was just
that she decides to go full transparent
and that that might not be a good thing
to do was the lesson I guess it's
unclear because there's no real conflict
in the film and then it ends and nothing
really gets accomplished she's still
going full transparent it doesn't
respect it didn't really resolve
anything for me to Tom Hanks is one of
my favorite actors and he was not in the
movie very much I enjoyed that he was
kind of the you know the villain of this
film you know if there is it's like oh
it's a bad film but that actors in it so
it can't be that bad
I was thinking that I wasn't even if the
circles not great Tom Hanks is in it so
they'll still be entertaining but he's
not even enough to make it entertaining
and then John boyega I think is that how
you sailing from Star Wars attention
thank you
he was uh barely in it at all I was
talking to a friend who had read the
book and I guess he's in it a lot and
you could see that watching it you like
understand that he should have been in
it a lot I didn't translate that way at
all of the skills you saw him like three
or four times and they were boring
scenes and though it was really flat and
this as well I think she was uh she was
fine like as an actress in like Harry
Potter and she fell flat for me in
beauty and Abby's a bit but I didn't
think it was a total disaster and this
was just like alright again pretty flat
but I feel like that was from the
direction to everyone was just kind of
flat there was no like Eddie
there's no stakes at all Karen Gillian
Karen Gillian I think that's her last
name she was good I enjoyed her - Utley
enjoyed her a lot more than Emma which
is odd
I wrote him playing phone notes I think
I like Emma more the human than an
actress I also broke I forgot a roses um
so she's always being watched always
even in her sleep 100% of the time and I
said but like when does she masturbate
because what her parents at one point
decide to go full transparent too
because her father has MS and they give
him free treatment as long as they go
full transparent so it's like this whole
family the vloggers the ultimate
vlogging family and then there's one
scene where they're having sex and
everyone goes nuts because they fuse
them having sex and then they go off the
grid and the pair's are the most sane
people also the most interesting
characters I think in this film cuz they
are like bringing up points that no one
else is like oh I think this is too much
maybe and I don't think that you
understand it is what it is and yeah why
don't you understand that Emma why again
I just don't think it transferred very
well to film the way that they handled
it I think I could see this being a
really cool super engaging book and it
just it didn't cross over for me at all
the relationships in the film also
didn't translate well at the point where
the parents are like well we're not
going to be full transparent anymore she
kind of loses her parents there in that
moment and they they kind of stop
talking to her a bit but you don't care
at all because I'm I was so flat the
whole time and none of those
relationships were built up I think the
one thing they did really well was
portray da the way that you're perceived
online and and the way that everyone has
to share everything all the time really
well that was very accurate there's a
point where she reads comments from her
like full transparency blog thing hi
Wendy
and she gets sad and she she feels like
a lot of shame from some of them and
there's a point where she shows one of
her friends makes chandeliers out of
deer antlers and a lot of people online
him for being a deer killer and that's
so real - and so really accurate
portrayal of that kind of thing I wrote
she's reading the comments never read
the comment sorry I'm from killing woody
I think they wanted it to be way more
relatable than it was I feel like the
book was probably a bit more relatable
or at least easier to get into in the
movie there's a point where they're
going to say that everyone who uses the
service has to vote and they have like
they know where they're at at all times
and it's very like I don't know if you
guys have heard about this within the
Bible in Christian beliefs there's like
a chip that in the end times you get
inserted with them and then you're
marked and you can you know be followed
everywhere and people can watch you and
it's similar to that in a way where it's
just like they have full control over
you at all times and there's some really
cool things that are like yeah I mean
everyone would already be registered to
vote awesome super cool some of these
things like makes sense but then it's
like on the opposite end of that this
isn't some of these anchor knots and and
are terrible I guess and it's just too
extreme of a thing to wear that everyone
in this world was on board with it
except for like a few select people is
weird because there would be giant
backlash and total people would just
like really fight against that if that
were the case so that was a little odd
all in all I think I'm so caught up on
them I guess the extreme it is of it
that don't make sense to me because the
movie itself was pretty boring there
really wasn't anything going on at all I
I enjoyed watching it it wasn't like I
was mad that I was there it was it was
interesting but it wasn't something I
don't want to see it again
I think Cody would be pretty upset about
it I did want to mention Bill Paxton was
in this and he was he was the dad and
his dad and and honestly one of the most
engaging characters for sure the dad and
mom were really sweet
and I wish they would have built up
their relationship more with Emma you
just didn't care about it at all but he
was great and he recently passed away so
um that was sad seeing him in that but
he was excellent I feel like it's such
an engaging topic like it could have
been such a cool thing but just totally
self lat
oh those are my my engaging thoughts on
that I um gosh I miss Cody
I love having someone here that I could
like talk back and forth with and either
agree or or or you know kind of debate
things with is so nice
he'll be back next week we're doing
guardians of the galaxy to which I'm
very excited about
I loved one I thought guardians of the
galaxy one was one of the most fun and
well done superhero movies ever Marvel
just hit it out of the park without one
so I'm really fancy tomb thank you so
much for watching I will see you next
week on Tamra Jessa and Cody Jessa also
as well I miss him Pacific bye
[Music]